I have a GPS ID and ID key I will provide you with their details like their API URL etc.
Bhavya, can you tell us a little bit about AuthConfig?
AuthConfig is basically an API of some vendors for which we need to call their tokens.
If we want to call their API.
So what is AuthConfig basically?
Suppose we have a login API from which we call their tokens.
Then we use that token to call their next API.
So AuthConfig is basically the same as if we want to call their API from the token itself.
And if we want to set up an API then what do we have to do in AuthConfig?
I will tell you about that.
If we have only one client then we will change the ID of that client.
For that we will set up AuthConfig.
For the other two, we are taking that as our priority.
Because we have only one client in which we have AuthConfig.
The other two don't have AuthConfig.
AuthConfig is something like this.
Some APIs are open to us.
And some APIs are the ones that we have to login first.
So we have the API from the vendor's side.
As soon as we run that API, we have tracked it.
The other thing is that we have run that API to the URL.
So we have to log in there.
That means some token will be added.
Token means login.
We will be able to test everything on that behalf.
So that is AuthConfig.
We have only one client in which we have AuthConfig.
We will discuss that later.
Before that, I will tell you about the other one.
Okay?
Okay, sir.
So before track confirmation, we have the API URL.
I have made some documents for all the clients.
So if we are looking at Springdale,
the API URL starts from here.
From HTTP.
This is a question mark.
These are our query patterns.
So all the parts before this are the API URL.
The starting part.
Okay?
So we will copy this and put it here.
In the API URL.
After this, we have methods.
There are three types of methods.
Get, Post, and Post.
If we send query patterns in the API.
If we attach something after the question mark.
We call this query pattern.
And if we send it in an object.
Like this.
We send it in an object.
We call this type of post request.
Okay.
Did you understand that much?
Yes.
Okay.
So for Springdale, we will call the get method.
I have written the method to get and post.
Okay.
So we will call the get method.
And then we have the query parameters.
We attach the token in this.
Or the extra values that we have to pass to call this.
We add those in this.
In this case, we have the token.
So we get the token.
And the value is also written in front of this.
Is equal to what?
This is the whole stream.
We have to copy and paste it here.
So we have to paste this after equal to?
Yes.
Token is equal to this.
From here to the end.
So every time we have to call the get method.
What are you doing?
Every time when we will hit the API,
we will have to call the get method.
Basically, what we are setting up,
we call the API on the backend.
We have to set up this setup once.
When we use this in our app,
we will call their other API,
which is our own API.
When we call that,
our backend automatically calls on the base of the config
on the base of the API.
Then we have headers.
Headers are basically what our response will be.
What format should it be in.
We can also fill this from here.
So here we will input accept.
And its value will be application slash json.
So that the response will be in json format.
Okay.
Now we have a bus.
One second.
Let me see the ID.
Is their API running?
Hello?
Yes.
Is their springdance API running?
It is running.
I can't hit their API.
You can directly check the API.
Postman?
No, it didn't work.
It might be an issue.
No, it's running.
Live location is unavailable.
It might be an issue.
Okay.
Entity change.
Tinku, you understood the API.
Yes, sir.
I understood even the headers.
Okay.
So in track config, we just have to put the API URL.
We have to set its method.
Which we have given.
And Tinku.
Okay.
So in track config, we just have to put the API URL.
We have to set its method.
Basically, it works mostly from Get and Post.
After that...
we have to attach the query parameter.
After that, we have to attach the query parameter itms.
And...
headers our accept, we can write path.
Okay.
What about request body?
Request body works when we make a post request.
For that to work...
For example...
So, like, get request or post request, what is the use case?
Like, what is the situation where you have to use the get, what is the situation where you have to post-release?
Situation wise, it depends on how they have configured the vendors in the API.
Okay, so, like it will be written to us from the beginning and we just need to put it over here.
Yes, yes, we have to call according to what they give us.
Okay, and here we have the test connection, if we have to call any API that you have configured, then we want to see the response.
Okay, and here you have the response configured.
Basically, suppose if we hit our app or portal, then how should we get the response in return?
Okay, how do we configure this? I will run an API.
There is an issue here.
What is the issue?
I have checked the fight.
I have hit the normal postman API, so it will hit here.
Okay, but when I do the same thing here, I set up everything here and get query parameters, then the response is giving us this.
Meaning there is some issue here.
This configuration will look like this, but there will be no track, right?
Yes, the test connection will not be checked, because based on the response of the test connection, we will configure the response.
Okay, no problem, get it set up once.
The entities will send me the word file.
I have made that JSON.
Yes, you will send it in the word file.
Okay, I will give it to you.
Don't copy it simply, send it either text file or word file.
By writing the name of the entity.
Okay, let me put it in the group.
Let's complete the setup first, then we will see how to tweak the test.
Okay, if I show it now, as I had shared it.
Let me show it.
Pinku, you have to be clear, first confirm that you have to do the setup.
The response config has not been done yet, the track config is clear.
You have to tell me the device ID as well, how to set up the device ID.
Have you put the device ID now?
How to put the device ID?
Okay, the wickle ID.
No, I couldn't check it there, I had to see that.
And this issue is coming from the check case side or from the switch side?
We will have to see, what is the front-end setup doing.
What is the front-end setup doing?
It is an issue from the front-end, the code is getting settled.
Okay, will you put this in there as well?
Put it in the same task.
Put it in the main task or in case?
Put it in the main task.
Okay.
Let me put the setup again, normally the response postman is coming.
Is the screen visible?
Matching key is equal to wickle number.
So we have to copy the wickle number mentioned here and add it here.
In the GPS ID key.
Okay, once again put it in the back.
Okay.
Just in matching key, because when we pass our ID,
we will pass our ID in this key and the back-end will match it with this key.
Okay.
And we will send this in the query parameter as well.
Okay, so this will be our setup in track config.
Then our response config.
This is basically the response of our vendor, vendor APEGA.
We set it up here.
What will be the path of the list?
If we talk about this, you can see here that the response is coming.
The list is coming inside the data.
Yes.
That is why we have written here data.list.
That is how we access the arrays from the dot operator.
Okay.
Okay, so data.list will be our path key.
Basically, it tells us that the data that will come from the vendor's APS will come in this.
That is, it will come in the list array.
Okay.
Then we have the match key.
The key that comes in this, the unique key,
that every wickle key is different.
Okay.
Then the latitude, longitude, and speed key.
This is basically the key, latitude, longitude, and speed.
We will copy these keys and insert them there.
I'm going to add the keys here.
That's all I have to say.
Is there any issue with this?
Just tell me about the match key.
The previous track config,
is it the same?
Yes, it's the same.
It's not the same.
The document that I'm going to give you,
it has a matching key in it.
It can be different.
We have to put the matching key in the track config
and the response will be in the match key.
Yes, the response will be in the match key.
Okay.
Then,
we have to put the deepest ID of each vehicle.
We have vehicles in transport.
Suppose,
if we want to configure this vehicle,
then we have to search for it in the response.
For example,
there's a wickle.
The matching key
that we added,
we have to set up
that wickle number of this vehicle,
we save it in the GPS ID.
Then it will go to our API
because it will bring the data based on this key.
Let's repeat the last one.
So if we call on our own, we will call on the value of this one.
Because then we will be able to match that our back end will also be able to check with this response.
Main comparison will be on this one only.
So what we have to do is take its value from here.
When we come to this page.
We will search the vehicle here.
When we view this, we have a GPS ID.
We will not be able to save that value here.
If we don't save it, it will not run on our app.
It will give an error that the GPS ID is configured in it.
We will save this.
Now if we come to our app.
Here we have the track wall bus option.
And if we go to 2954.
When we click on this.
Now if we go to the vehicle's app.
One second.
Here it goes to our app.
In this we are sending the GPS ID.
Which we had set up there.
By going to our vehicle.
We will pass it here.
So what happens on the back end?
The internal track that we have configured.
It will run from this GPS ID key.
And then the response will only be given by this vehicle.
And then whatever is the latitude and longitude.
We will enter it here.
Okay.
So how much is the setup?
Now suppose here it is 5861.
We don't have GPS ID.
We haven't set it up.
So here we get an error.
Please contact us.
Okay.
Now tell us if there are any doubts in the setup.
Yes.
You just told us that we will get it in the documents.
Like matching.
Where will we get the response from?
We will provide that too.
No.
Right now.
The response will not come on the portal.
There will be an error.
So you have to do the postman first.
Yes.
So in one case you can do it on the postman.
Okay.
Just in case.
I am asking.
I can find out what data to put on the postman.
But the thing is.
Can you tell us where the show is on the front end?
So that when it gets updated, we can do it from there.
Okay.
Where will the response come on the front end?
Yes.
Here is the track config.
Here it is written test connection.
Okay.
If you click on this, it runs on A.
Right now it is coming here.
Okay.
But the response will come here.
The postman should also come here.
Okay.
Yes.
That's all.
Are you sure?
Yes.
I showed the pipe one.
But the response is not coming here.
Okay.
Where to set up GPSID?
Like it was shown on the web portal.
I showed it on the web portal.
Did you clear it?
Yes.
Okay.
We have to complete the setup.
Till 4 p.m.
Okay.
Please share it.
I will add the entities in your ID.
Okay.
It has to be set up on QA.
QA?
Yes.
What are you saying Priya?
All the QA?
Yes. All the QA.
But you will add only two buses.
You will add only two buses.
Then we will do the same setup on production.
Okay.
You have to complete the 4th one.
Send me the list. I will add it in their ID.
I will send the data to them.
I told you.
I will send it to them.
It is easy to read.
Yes.
Tinku, tell me how is this for you?
Sir,
I wanted to ask you something.
You told me that we have to do the setup.
We have to do two buses.
Do we have to do two buses?
Or after two buses,
we have to do another one in the next entity?
We have to do two buses for every entity.
For every entity.
Okay sir.